it's interesting that you have you're
having so much success and sort of
popular success with films that on the
face of it you you don't think we'd kind
of resonate in the way that they have
like this or call me by your name I mean
how surprised were you when that film
found this you don't know absolutely and
I man that's why I'm so honored to be up
here with you Laura as well like I I
love movies I love acting I love going
to movies I was kind of getting scared
when I was younger that maybe he was
becoming like opera or something like an
outdated art form or something and you
see like searches movies you see lures
movies you see Stevens like you know
either
these are great hopefully these are
great things the way forward and the
yourself an army hammer when you weren't
going by your name so you yeah there you
are yeah and you you get this wonderful
opportunity you go off to Italy to make
it right but it's only the director
really threw you in at the deep end yes
this is true so day one day one he oh
yeah I didn't anything no we had a
rehearsal with the army that um you know
we basically had to break the ice and
our army tells us we're we're better
than I do but uh we had to do a
rehearsal outside and Luca made it seem
very spur-of-the-moment like we're gonna
rehearse any scene but then when once we
got outside he like had a very specific
page number to turn to it happened to be
the first make out in the movie or the
first kiss so army never come with me so
like all right here we go I'm like and
so Luca said you know dive into it and
we started making out and there was no
stop there was no like cut so we like
we're wait like a minute or two minutes
and then like stop making out and Luke
was gone
[Music]
[Applause]
you